(dramatic violin music)
- [Queen Elizabeth] What's
your view of the Jubilee?
- You must do it.
- Must I do that alone?
- There is only one queen.
- Want to know more
about the Silver Jubilee
that revived the queen's popularity
and swept the gloom away from Britain?
Then keep watching for
the fascinating true story
behind the controversial event.
I'm Laura Jackson and this
is "Beneath the Crown."
1977: the year that marked 25 years
since Queen Elizabeth the
Second's accession to the throne,
but much of the United
Kingdom wasn't in the mood
to get the Silver Jubilee party started.
- What a mess, I mean honestly,
can you remember a time
when the country was in a worse shape?
- Britain was struggling economically,
politically, and socially.
There was mass unemployment, rising crime,
growing racial tensions,
strike after strike.
- Right now the United
Kingdom is the equivalent
of a patient dying on the operating table,
and the surgeons, no, the butchers,
no, sorry, the murderers
responsible for causing that death
are seeking re-election.
- Despite significant
opposition due to the high cost,
it was decided the Silver
Jubilee celebrations
would go ahead on June the 7th.
The actual anniversary
of the Queen's accession was in February,
a date which would also mark 25 years
since her father's untimely death.
The Queen chose to push
the date back to June.
Enthusiasm for Jubilee
Day was initially low,
but as it drew nearer, the
public warmed to the idea
as if it were an escape from the gloom.
Suddenly, Silver Jubilee memorabilia
started popping up everywhere.
Lord Snowden was tasked with
designing several souvenirs.
- The powers that be
thought it might be nice
if someone from inside
the firm were to design
some of the memorabilia.
- Oh Tony, you are clever.
- Always happy to help my family.
- Other items on offer was
somewhat less conventional.
You could call someone on a Jubilee phone,
play someone with Jubilee cards,
strike a light with Jubilee matches
and even keep your trousers
up with a Jubilee belt.
There was also a range of
Silver Jubilee underwear.
The less said about them, the better.
One thousand pounds was
given to every borough
in Britain towards the celebrations.
Street parties were organized
up and down the nation.
Decorations sprung up everywhere.
There was a mood of jubilation
and togetherness that harked
back to the coronation.
(upbeat jazz music)
- How lovely.
- Anarchic punk group the Sex Pistols
launched a blistering
attack on the monarchy
with their song, "God Save The Queen".
It struck a chord with many
despite widely banned
from British TV and radio.
There were fears it would
top the UK singles chart
in Jubilee week and
cause huge embarrassment.
The crisis was averted when the
song only reached number two
behind unlikely royal
savior Rod Stewart's track,
"I Don't Want To Talk About It".
Rumors persist that a
record business conspiracy
may have kept it off the top spot.
The queen was said to be
furious about the song,
although it was reported
that Prince Charles
found it rather amusing.
But when Jubilee day
arrived on June the 7th,
the nation turned to celebration.
The opposition to the day was overshadowed
by the estimated 10 million people
who attended street parties.
There were roughly a 125 thousand of them,
with five thousand in London alone.
Not even the rain kept people away.
A global audience of
half a billion watched
as Her Majesty took the golden state coach
from Buckingham Palace
to St. Paul's Cathedral,
with Prince Charles
following on horseback.
The roar of the one million strong crowd
meant the coachmen couldn't even hear
the sound of the horse's
hooves hitting the road.
A carefully choreographed
walkabout through London
allowed spectators to
indulge in a bit of chit-chat
with the Queen and Prince Phillip,
before they headed to
lunch at the Guild Hall.
There, she delivered a speech
in the presence of the Lord Mayor.
- My Lord Mayor, when I was 21,
I pledged my life to the
service of our people.
I do not regret nor
retract one word of it.
- That night, the Sex Pistols
took to the River Thames
for a protest concert, which included
playing "Anarchy In The
UK" opposite Parliament.
It wasn't long before they were arrested.
Looking back at it, it's crazy
that the sight of a golden carriage,
the ultimate statement
of wealth and privilege,
gave so much joy to a public
largely short of money.
The Silver Jubilee provided
an excuse to people
to share something and come
together on a massive scale.
- [Queen Elizabeth] That's
the thing about the monarchy.
We paper over the cracks.
And if what we do is loud, and
grand, and confident enough,
no one will notice that all
around us it's falling apart.
- That's the point of us.
- [Queen Elizabeth] Not us. You.
(energetic cello music)